Speaker 1: former President Mike Pence has
been doing the rounds mostly to sell his book
and maybe to kind of softly prod at the possibility
of a 2024 presidential run.
And he appeared on a Fox News program called
Outnumbered.
The gag with Outnumbered is that it's four
female hosts and they invite on a man each
show and the man is outnumbered.
Okay, that's the idea.
Check out.
So context.
This interview that Pence gave is almost as
bad as some of.
Trump's worst interviews.
It's really something to see.
Check out how dynamic and funny and clever
and charismatic Mike Pence is right off the
bat.
And of course, I'm kidding.
He's none of those things.
Speaker 3: Hello, everyone.
This is outnumbered.
I'm Emily Companion.
And joining me today, Carley Shimkus, Martha
MACCALLUM and ainsley earhardt.
And we are honored to have on the former vice
president of the United States, Mike Pence.
It is his first time on Outnumbered.
And sir, we are thrilled and honored to have
you here with us today.
Speaker 2: Oh, it's great to be here.
Although I do feel outnumbered.
Speaker 1: You know, it's it's great to be
here.
Carley Shimkus.
But I do feel.
Outnumbered.
Just charisma dripping off of this guy, reeking
of charisma.
And of course, we're all cringing very, very
hard.
Now, there were some interesting questions
posed to Pence.
More interesting was, was the way that he
answered these questions.
He was asked, do you want to be the president
of the United States?
Speaker 3: I don't have a lot of time.
So I think one of the first ones I want to
ask you is what is on everyone's mind, because
this is a foundation for people understanding
you and your life.
We often see books come out from people who
are saying, I want to be president of the
United States.
So my first question is, do you want to be
president of the United States?
Speaker 2: Well, Martha, I would say no more,
no less than any other kid that grew up with
a cornfield in his backyard.
Speaker 1: So is that a yes or a no?
Speaker 2: You know, I can tell you the dream
of public service animated my youth as I write
about in the book the opportunity I had to
represent my hometown in Congress to be governor
of Indiana and ultimately to serve as your
vice president is deeply humbling to me.
But Karen and I are going to take time over
the holidays.
You know, we have to in the military so we
would between deployments are our kids have
not all been back in Indiana for the last
three years together.
So we'll take time to reflect, deliberate,
talk to the kids and oh, we're going to we're
going to make a decision about what our next
calling is, but I promise to keep you posted.
Speaker 3: But when you do that, when you.
Speaker 1: Yeah, let me interpret this answer
for you in, you know, standard Republican
speak and to some degree politicians speak.
I don't know if I'd have a shot at winning
right now, Martha.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to bring
in consultants and pollsters to figure out,
do I have a shot?
And if I do have a shot, I'm going to probably
try to go for it, particularly if I believe
that even in losing it might raise my profile
or somehow be advantageous to me in some way,
shape or form.
Now, one of the things that is a little bit
different is that as a former V.P., it's one
thing to lose the general election for president
as a former VP.
Happened to Al Gore, for example.
But to lose the Republican primary as a former
VP and in particular to run against the president
you served under.
That's a little bit different.
And that I don't I don't know.
Has that happened in history?
I don't know off the top of my head.
But that's sort of a different thing and a
different, different consideration.
A couple other clips here citing absolutely
no evidence whatsoever.
He starts talking about how Twitter and Elon
Musk are being targeted by Biden because of
something related to the Hunter Biden story.
Check this out.
Speaker 2: The suggestion that the president
of the United States is keeping a close eye
on on any element of the media is deeply offensive
to me.
It's it's it's your job in the media to keep
a close eye on elected officials.
So I lived in that world for 20 years as a
congressman, as a governor, and as your vice
president.
And.
But I do think, as you suggest, I think it
may well be because Elon Musk, who I came
to know very well during the four years of
the Trump administration.
Well, I think it's because he is preparing
to release information finally about the suppression
of the Hunter Biden story.
Speaker 1: So this is like two layers of stuff.
First of all, there's no evidence that anything
that's going on has to do with the Hunter
Biden story.
But again, if all you have is a hammer, everything
looks like a nail.
Must be related to Hunter Biden.
That's number one.
But the funniest and honestly, the scariest
part of this is Pence saying, you know, a
White House keeping an eye on the media.
Trump had a hit list of media people that
he didn't like.
Trump wanted to kick people out of the pressroom.
Trump did kick some people out of the press
room like Jim Acosta from CNN briefly, although
he eventually went back, he says it's chilling
or whatever phraseology he used for an administration
to be keeping an eye on the media.
The Trump administration was maybe the modern
administration most adversarial and hostile
to journalism and to the media and to a free
press.
It's absolutely bonkers.
Now, one last clip here.
I won't even introduce this one.
Just listen.
Speaker 3: I want to ask you a question about
your faith, because we share the same faith.
But how do you know that that is God calling
you?
Because everywhere you go, people love you.
How even Democrats love you because you're
just a nice, wholesome, good person who does
the right thing.
And and you're honest.
You're honest.
But they might not like your politics, but
they like who you are and your character.
Speaker 1: So I love that.
First of all, everybody loves you.
Democrats love you.
It wasn't Democrats don't love them.
And the MAGA people wanted them killed on
January 6th.
So I don't know what on earth Ainsley EARHARDT
is talking about, but I love the question.
How do you know that that's God really speaking
to you?
It's sort of like one of these things where
Bush said he spoke to God and God told him
to invade Iraq.
And then, you know, all these stories that
are told, I checked with God and God said
to go ahead to do it or God chose this.
Was it maybe just indigestion and God not
really speaking to you?
I just absolutely love that.
How do you know it really is God speaking
to you?
And of course, the question has its own internal
logic for those who believe God speaks to
them or might or speaks to some people.
How do you know that that's really God?
Speaking to you is a very logical question.
They never have an actual good answer, but
it's just so funny to hear Ainsley Earhart
say, How do you know?
And also just everyone loves you.
No, no, that's not true.
The Democrats don't love him and half of the
Republicans don't love him.
And some of that half wanted him killed on
January 6th.
Unbelievable stuff.
And Pence seems to be in the running for interviews,
as absurd as those that we have seen from
Donald Trump will have all these Pence clips
on our Instagram, which you can find at David
Pakman show and remember.
You got to be subscribed on YouTube.
Subscribe to The David Pakman Show YouTube
channel.
If you watch the clips, but that subscribe
button is enabled, hit that button.
It is free.
All you're saying when you hit subscribe is
I affirm The David Pakman Show.
You're not paying anything.
You're not committed to anything.
You're just saying, I affirm this.
I affirm the content.
Affirm.
Okay, hit that subscribe button.
We're going to take a quick break and be back
right after this.